[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
my guest today for the 10th episode of
the joke world podcast he's written on
snl he's written for the oscars up here
on the joe rogan experience nimish patel
what's up man thanks for having me so
out of those last few things that i just
listed where would you say this zoom
interview for joke world lands
it's the high number four
so yeah you're someone who obviously is
an amazing stand-up on stage but also
does a lot of joke writing off stage
which i think is kind of unique based on
other people we've talked to has mostly
just been about stand up but when you're
writing something for like snl or for
the oscars do you ever think it's weird
when you you know you put a lot of
effort into your jokes so then someone
else gets to have the laughs no i think
uh uh i think that's a very cool thing
you still get the same you still get a
very similar satisfaction from it
obviously it's not the
the same experience but then
you're not necessarily writing
the same jokes for
the same like i wouldn't do
uh uh some of the jokes i've written for
snl or whatever on stage it's more like
it's for that show you know yeah that
makes sense and you're someone on stage
who i would say has like
probably the most relaxed like calm
delivery like it it really looks like
you are the most comfortable person ever
when you're on stage yeah i mean a lot
of that is uh
a practice but it is i've always felt um
comfortable stage i never had a stage or
anything like that so even like day one
like first ever open mic up were you up
there still you know leaning on the wall
and just like no i mean no no that's
that's come from i mean the comfort's
been
uh what's it called like i said
rehearse but it's also come from having
been on stage building time so my first
time on stage was uh chris rock
impression you know
all black you know talking about
politics and all that kind of stuff
moving around a bit and really animated
but yeah i know that that it was uh
a phase in my life um but i thought like
you know when i started coming down and
realized uh you had to be yourself
and uh once that kicked in it was it's
been pretty cheap yeah so have you
always been in new york then is that
where you started off uh i started i
mean i lived in uh uh jersey in new york
my whole life you know i was born and
raised in jersey and then went to nyu so
i've been in new york since 04
minus like a year and a half at home
after graduating
um
but yeah i started i started new
brunswick new jersey at stress factory
and uh nice stuff and then every open
mic after that
was the mean streets of
new york man just cut my teeth yeah
obviously there's so much going on there
and it's one of the biggest if not the
biggest city for comedy in the world uh
could you imagine starting a career
anywhere else do you think it'd be a lot
harder or are there challenges that are
just in new york
i
uh
have no i cannot imagine having started
in
anywhere that isn't new york city uh
just because
there's more stage time here than there
is anywhere else yeah um and that that's
and i'm saying that not having been to a
lot of the scenes anywhere else and i
just know for a fact uh-huh sheboygan
mentioned michigan detroit is not gonna
have you know seven open my eight ten
open mics a night that you can go to
that you know about there's probably
like 20 that you don't know about that
are still popping you know yeah yeah
sure and the city always had you know
the city is a mecca of
all kinds of culture and stuff so
there's there's like um
you know like music open mics poetry
over mics like the combo of all them and
comics are welcome at most of them so uh
i think starting out in new york where
that was like a big thing you get
audiences real fast because
they're not just comedy yeah want to be
comedians that makes sense uh was a huge
impact on
uh
myself for sure and then any other
person that started out doing comedy in
new york yeah that's funny you mentioned
detroit because i started doing comedy
in in cleveland okay um i moved to tampa
now but in cleveland it was like i knew
of like all right i got one on
wednesdays that i can go to right and
then i got maybe one on a monday also
and then other than that it's just like
there's like two days of a week and
they're sure i'm there's a lot that i
didn't know about but yeah that is crazy
so there's 13 in one night in uh i think
that was that wasn't like a regular
thing it was i challenged myself to see
i i did the math how many you could do
in a night i think i got through
13 was the most on like a tuesday this
is like 10 years ago 11 years ago but i
think i did nine or ten wow same set
each time
but yeah i mean not the same set uh but
like
uh similar jokes definitely definitely
just going through like
a seven minute set you know uh with five
minutes so like you know switching
things in and out but uh by the last set
my voice was gone it was like i was
tired that's a crazy night so the the
comedy seller is your main club right
that'd be like your home
base
and then how does that work when you're
past at a club and you have like a a
home club and then there's also all
these other shows in the city do you
do you even have well you could you
could do you know every i think most
comedy people know that um
stage time is the most important thing
so
i don't at least i hope not that there's
not a lot of oh you're here you can't
work there kind of thing it's just
right if you're good enough you can work
wherever um and i'm fortunate that you
know i can go
to any of the clubs and and get some
time you know yeah for sure and then uh
you know most so how i first saw you i
it was years ago just like these clips
that come out and it's like you're one
of the most recognizable comedians on
the internet i think in just like clip
form and just like especially for crowd
work specifically that's some of my
favorite things oh thank you that i have
seen of yours and obviously you're not
i've talked to other people about this
before like who love to put crowd work
on the internet and their clips whether
it be tick tock or reels because a lot
of people you know the fans like to see
that authentic stuff they know you're
coming up with it off the top of your
head and you can burn that material
without having to burn material
but then the flip side of that which is
i'm curious about is there an
expectation that you think that you're
setting when you're on tour or when
people are coming to see a show with
your name on it that like they're going
to be in the crowd they might be
trying to get noticed or like trying to
get you to do crowd work i definitely i
definitely have noticed that uh
people's expectations of comedy
are really based on what they see in the
clips uh you know a lot of people do
expect crowd work and stuff and i
definitely
uh
oblige when it comes when if the
opportunity is present but i've been uh
it's it's also a lot more fun to be like
like i have a very a few dark jokes that
i tell like very early in the set just
to just like like oh you thought i was
just gonna do crowd work for 45 minutes
yeah uh uh just to let them know that
that's not what they're coming to see oh
that's what they think they've come to
see but that's not what's gonna happen i
definitely had one or two moments where
people have been trying to get noticed
but for the most part people are just
like
hyped to the experience and it's always
fun to
have them expect x and give them you
know
four or like whatever you know like a
completely different experience than
what they thought was gonna happen yeah
uh
and that's what i've been doing you know
uh the the show the set right now is uh
nothing they've seen on the internet uh
nothing they've seen on tick tock it's
none other thank you china materials no
it's very little crowd work um except
you know again like to get into the set
and stuff but yeah
that makes sense that that makes a lot
of sense is there ever a time where
something crazy will happen in the
uh crowd that you know you have to
address and it's about it has a lot of
potential for crowd work does your mind
ever go to
like the clips on accident while you're
up there and take you out of that like
oh this is going to be really good on
tick tock no i mean i mean i'm always
uh i try to stay as present as possible
i'm not trying to think of what the clip
is going to be and all that kind of
stuff but when
i think recently in nashville someone
yelled that i watch you while i poop and
i was just like i said yeah that's going
on the internet you know that was just
like one of those that was like you know
you know it when you when it happens
like oh this is gonna be a thing yeah um
and a lot of times like
there's definitely moments in the show
that are
designated content generation time where
it's like all right well i've done
55 minutes to an hour what my material
is um what i actually want to talk about
and now let's give the machine what it
wants and let's give the people what
they want which is
some of what they want which is you know
me talking to them having figuring out
like what's going on in their lives and
it's all not
it's none of it's prepared um i just
you know
it's not it's not a secret skill of any
kind to know what's gonna
uh
um
do well on in that well but not even
that like what's gonna
get people to say some wild [ __ ] or like
oh like what questions you have to be
asked yeah yeah yeah yeah
but you know the expectations for me
for my and for a crowd is just to be
present and attentive
um and then whatever happens happens you
know i don't go into it thinking this is
the tick tock show it's more right if
something happens and it's going to
happen right have you done the phones in
the bags at any shows like the um i did
it when i taped the special uh and then
i'm not sure if i did i'm not sure if i
i probably did but i can't recall any
particular moment denver the phones were
in the bag so that's because the club
does it um and then when i whenever i do
my show in the city at big beach uh in
new york city at big beach i lock
people's ones up but that's only because
uh it's usually me trying to [ __ ] out
and uh um i want people to be present
when i do that
is that the comedy works in denver that
does the bags yeah yeah nice i've heard
everyone's just raves about that club
whether it's i'm editing podcasts or
talking to someone what makes that so
different
it's a fantastic club i i don't think uh
that the phones
has nothing to do i think the phone's
being locked up is a one a very small
part but no less a part of what makes
them so successful
as a
comedy venue from an audience
perspective and the convenience
perspective the room is just designed uh
to carry laps well
people are tightly packed but yet still
feel enough space to laugh however they
want it's almost like theater seating
it's like very low staggered okay it's
it's not like flat so okay it feels
everything's got a crazy viewpoint um
and if there's tables in there
it's like um
those little school desks that you had
like one on the side yeah not a full
table in front of you so it's great but
yeah it's like sweet
and the elevation's high so people are
even higher the alcohol hits a bit
better you know it's hard to say but all
those things combined make for a
fantastic club and the staff is
incredible the the owner is great like
everything is just it's a well-run shop
you know yeah yeah that makes a lot of
sense and everything's legal there so
yeah and i'll be there in august and you
heard it here first or probably not
first but it'll be there or not you
heard it yeah you heard it here so
you're someone who talks about clips i
feel like like the tick tock clips and
like how that can translate into real
life ticket sales across the country
kind of the way that some older
comedians you hear talk about when they
first started a podcast and they're like
i don't know what this is going to be
but eventually they were like oh people
are coming to my show saying i saw you
from this the podcast and the podcast
turned into tickets and then you are
kind of i feel like you're the person
that's saying that same thing about
clips instead of podcasts to the tickets
so when did that first like when was the
first time you realized oh this is more
than just for my own instagram this is
more than is reaching more than just
people who already know who i am yeah i
think it was you know i could almost
pinpoint it exactly it was uh you know
my wife told me to get on tick-tock like
two years ago um and then another friend
told me and then i finally listened
that's a life lesson like always listen
to your wife first but
i think it was like i would say april of
2021 when
i mean i started putting out a bunch of
stand up before that on tick tock and
what have you made a few clips here and
there um
but
in april 2021 like something took off i
forget which flip did but then i started
putting i feed it i started feeding the
machine a lot
and i had these shows lined up in
houston um at
a comedy hub
and
i was using the clips to see if i
couldn't direct tickets to that show
okay and it worked and like i went from
you know one 70-seat show to
four
200-seat shows damn um and so i sold out
sold out houston and then we're like oh
let's see we can't do dallas yeah i did
dallas sold that out on a wednesday like
holy [ __ ]
ramadan like austin sold out yeah four
shows like it was it was just like wow
smiling and i was like now i called my
manager my like we were like i was like
yo this could be a real thing
and then
we got my agent on board tj and uh
it just
just went off you know i was just
talking about this earlier it was like
at one point i had you know
march
2021 had zero dates on my calendar by
may i was booked through you know the
year like it was just crazy
that's that's insane yeah it was just
kind of nuts like and you know a lot of
it was
clubs taking a shot being like oh yeah
we got a tuesday free and then we go
coming in and selling out a tuesday
which meant to them or could probably
sell out a [ __ ] weekend right um
because you know like
people buy more tickets on on the
weekend obviously so
it was like
uh a real
everyone had a very quick learning
process
yeah
from myself to
agent manager to the clubs like oh [ __ ]
this could be a real thing
and uh
uh i'm very grateful for
just the opportunity to recognize that
opportunity you know yeah yeah it was
present like to me it was just like let
me just throw [ __ ] out there i got all
this material like i've been trying on
youtube it's done a little well but it's
not taking off the way i wanted to and
then tick tock just kind of accelerated
everything and it almost seems like it's
a new york thing right now to be like
like you sam morrell like mark norman
these are like the clip
masters i feel like like andrew schultz
like these are like guys that are just
ripping clips and they're always going
like constantly constantly going viral
even if you don't like comedy a lot of
people have probably seen some new york
comedians faces from just viral viral
clips yeah i mean we've just uh
been fortunate enough to be in positions
where we have tons of material we can
throw away we have a team or group of
people that would be able to edit and
clip stuff out put stuff up and uh
um
you know
all praise the algorithm you know he's
doing great schulz yeah everyone's
everyone who's uh uh
taking advantage of that and they should
right um
for better for worse is putting their
stuff out there and i think that's the
if uh
that's one takeaway from my success or
shoulder success or anyone else's
success is like
put your [ __ ] out there and if it's good
you know hopefully people it will
resonate with people yeah for sure do
you think this might be a really stupid
question but
tick tock and all these reels are like
so addicting is it hard to have all this
stuff like be part of your job or you
have to be uploading your own stuff and
then you might waste an hour of your
probably pretty busy day because it's
like it was a it was a huge tax on my
time
uh for
four months or so when i was doing it
myself
and then i hired a team to
uh do the execution of it all yeah you
know find the stuff put it up caption it
all that kind of figure out content
playing all that kind of stuff yeah
obviously with a lot of my oversight and
input but right like that actual process
of uploading and writing [ __ ] out was so
time consuming and consumed like like
not just an hour like
so much of my day yeah
that the cost benefit of hiring someone
to do it all was well worth it yeah was
it hard to give up
your the power the control of your art
to another person no i mean it's not
really there's no they don't necessarily
have any control beyond like they know
my passwords and [ __ ] but
she still picked the jokes and yeah
they'll they'll
they'll just be like hey do you want to
do this one you want to use this so i'm
like yeah yeah like these i i know all
the stuff so i'm like okay that's fine
all right and i'll give some direction
in terms of let's try this one this
today or like i'm not really vibing with
this joke anymore i don't want to use it
like how i look or anything like that
but for the most part it's like
i don't say set i didn't forget it
because it's still very interactive with
myself and the team but it is like
that execution part is is off my hands
which is you know a huge part of the
battle right that make that makes sense
is it is it
a certain demo that's coming out from
clips so then you can tell that oh those
are clip people and is it a different
demo that you can tell is like
i don't know just
more they've seen you in other clubs or
maybe in new york and they're like here
for because most of your clips i think
is is more crowdwork and off the cuff so
is is there more can you tell when
someone is there that has seen maybe
your other hour or has seen you in other
shows well i do it i i make it a point
to
to ask who's there from tick tock or
who's that from youtube okay from
instagram
um
just for my own notification to see like
what's been happening yeah all you get
diving further back which clip was it
for you that did it you know you're
doing in-person analytics just yeah
and
more and more because
because i have the special um and
because i had the mixtape that i put out
uh
in december
i have
you know a hundred or so clips
that aren't
crowd those it's just pure jokes
and those are
those are
doing better and better from the
uh
from the views perspective like they're
they're getting a lot of hits and that's
really what the goal is right it's right
let you know that
i don't just do crowd working that's not
going to be crowded quick under the show
if you like stand up you will get a
full-on stand-up show you will get a
full-on stand-up experience from what
when you come to see me
and more and more it's becoming just
like people who saw like uh uh this clip
i have about bats which is you know in a
hindu sector a clip i have about mdma
that i've that i put out at one point
you know it's just like random stuff
yeah and then there's still obviously
some people who have come from the viral
uh [ __ ] on a trump supporter or
making fun of the coast guard clips and
all that kind of stuff but
um
i still think it's the balance is more
towards the crowd work stuff only
because those clips have existed for a
lot longer and the virality is a lot
stronger but
as i shift away from that stuff and i'll
still have i'll still interject i'll
still inject you know crowd working all
that kind of stuff
um
i'm hoping more and more will be just
people who are there because they saw
a joke clip you know that's pretty sick
that's that's a cool way to to
do this whole thing and of the comedy
experience like that's it's kind of
groundbreaking in a way like you're i
hope so yeah i mean look i don't i don't
like to do my own horn uh too much but
um
[Music]
i think from a stand-up perspective
um and from a marketing perspective
what you know myself and a few peers are
doing is uh
uh demonstrating what can be done yeah
i'm proud of that you know so you
mentioned the album and the uh special
that you just released was about a month
ago now yeah thank you yes sir so the so
the album is is something that's i feel
like pretty unique you know like it was
maybe a thing that people used to do
then kind of gotta wait maybe i'm wrong
kind of got away from and then
now might be coming back just a strict
audio album that you put on spotify
yeah
i i have
i have two albums um both of which are
like well the first album is called um i
don't know i remember what it's called
uh
uh
what is it called i don't remember um
the one that's on spotify and the most
recent one i put out is called it's dark
and patella's high
um and and that is uh
that's that's like visual and
um
yeah it wasn't it wasn't just a
uh
an audio on the album i call it mixtape
because it was all the stuff that was
cut from the special oh oh that's that's
sick so i did like two hours i wrote two
hours last year while i was on the road
and in one hour i turned to thank you
china and then
uh the mixtape which is all the stuff
that i cut from the hour it's called the
stock and patella's hot that i also put
out on youtube was that was that always
the plan is try to get two hours in this
year then do a mixtape and a special yes
that was always a plan um
and by always i mean like
i think three months into the tour it
became very apparent that i was going to
have way too much [ __ ] material um
but that i was very happy with all the
things i'd written and i was like i
don't wanna i'm not gonna i want to burn
it but i'm not gonna just never do it
again
i will do it in uh at a show and record
all of them and put it out it's a great
problem to have just yeah i know too
many jokes yeah it's any mission charge
that's the name of the first album okay
oh yeah yeah
is it unique i feel like because you
know you listen to other people and
they're like yeah i craft my one hour
and it takes me a year and a half for
this is it unique to be able to pump out
two hours of of really good funny
material in a year i have no idea what
is uh unique and what is and i just know
what i've done
right because i'm not a big student of
comedy um
like i know who i like i i've i've
watched a good amount of the stuff that
i like but
you know i i know uh same moral and mark
norman can quote you know jokes from
george carlin and whoever else from like
like almost like autistically they well
actually on this album minute this time
you know like robin williams said this
i'm like oh that's great uh i i know
some patrice stuff you know yeah um
so
all that to say like it
i i'm nothing if not prolific um i just
i just write a ton
yeah and i'm also like
uh
not as harsh on my jokes as some people
might be with theirs so i'm sure i'm
sure
all the comics i've written tons of [ __ ]
and just done nothing with it or like
it's just in a joke folder somewhere
whereas i'm just like i'm less precious
with um all the stuff i'm just like here
it is
i probably won't commit much more time
to make this any better than it is like
enjoy it while it's here yeah
just listen to it and if you like it you
like it not no matter so we're saying
writing are you a pen to paper guy or on
stage working out an idea kind of like
both both you know it's more like a
pen to pad whenever i can if i got
nothing else in front of me
evernote when i'm
uh
structuring a set or organizing my stuff
and then um
on stage i'm just
i'll say stuff
to go like in between the bullet points
that i had in my brain like oh yeah okay
oh that's funny and that's fine
and i just trust my ability to come up
with some stuff on the spot and yeah
that'll once i say something on stage
for the most part it'll it'll remain in
my head
and then hopefully through repetition
i'll i'll make sure that that remains in
the set
yeah that makes sense then a lot of
people talk about
how podcasting especially individual
podcasting can help them write jokes or
has helped them
write jokes you i i believe are not a
very big in on podcasting
what is uh you just
that's not true look i tried i had a
podcast for a while called gucci turban
uh my friend joseph yeah um and we did a
few episodes it just became too
difficult logistically
and then
i i had a patreon for a little while
where i was monday nights i was talking
to people um
my youtube fan base you know talking the
camera high or not high just
bullshitting and trying new stuff out
and
once the tour picked up
it became
impossible it's like right i'll be on
the show i'll be at a show or i'm just
like my brain's too uh
focused on the set to like come up with
a bunch of new stuff um that i want to
throw away to these patreon people like
i already just come to a show and have a
good time versus
uh i got to deliver a bunch of stuff to
you it became it became too taxing i'm
sure i'll pick it up again and see if i
can't
uh make some fun stuff happen like if
i'm off the road but for now it's just
well that's what's so interesting kind
of what i was saying before is that like
your your clip game is basically your
podcast in a way
if the end goal is for everyone to be
moving tickets
no matter who cares like what the steps
are then like
you can do that and not have to sit
there for two hours a week
yeah if the goal is to i mean i'm sure i
could
somehow sell more tickets but then you
gotta advertise the podcast you know
right it's like it's just another thing
you gotta market to have people to come
and all that kind of stuff is just like
yeah and time to stick to what i'm good
at yeah i'll stick to what i'm good at
which is being on stage and [ __ ]
around and
writing from that perspective so that is
crazy that like the two things that seem
to work is either three hours of you
talking or 60 seconds of you talking
yeah there's not like an in between
there they're opposite things yeah
i mean i i
i've never been much of a talker
which is an odd thing to say as a
comedian i'm actually you know fairly
quiet and introverted but
um
but the stage is just like
the an easy way to let me talk
yeah so
if if i'm doing that then there's no
need for me to talk for three hours um
to find you know to make fun of
uh the prime minister of japan getting
assassinated somehow you know like yeah
i can do that on stage and much rather
do that in a in a stage context versus
like me talking to a friend of mine or
bullshitting for no reason you know yeah
and see the people laughing and enjoying
your content with your own eyes exactly
instead of just a comment that was like
i like this yeah right
um
yeah that is that is a good point so
then you we don't have to talk about the
columbia thing but when you went on joe
rogan which is a podcast obviously i
just said joe rogan's that's okay
obviously that's a podcast
that's very big and was there any nerves
i mean you're a little less established
than you are now just because that's how
years work and time like was it like
nervous going in there like how did did
the only thing i was nervous about was
uh smoking his weed yeah but i'm glad he
didn't offer because i definitely would
have said yes and then that [ __ ] would
have gone off the rails because i got a
fairly light tolerance um when it comes
to
like famous people weed
but you got to say yes yeah like he
didn't he didn't offer he didn't offer
i don't i don't think so i don't think
he was no he wasn't that'd be kind of
weird i guess if he was yeah that would
have been
yeah just but no no nerves he was just
the nicest dude you know had a great
time
is it is it you go in there is he like
well you kind of knew what you were
going to talk about so maybe that was a
little easier but it lasts for so long
like i always wonder like how do you
i mean hopefully you just get lost in
the conversation but how do you not just
keep like for that long have have
moments where you're like oh my god
oh i mean joe's joe's great carrying
conversation on top of that luckily we
didn't talk for three hours he had
enough he had you know two guests booked
that day so i was just like i was in
there for like an hour and a half or two
and we were done
that sounds terrible to me having two
three guests booked in one day and all
yeah just wait till you get a hundred
million dollars to talk to you all oh
that's great
yeah i'd talk all day i guess yeah yeah
exactly what you said earlier about
being introverted but you're also a
comedian which is like kind of kind of
strange but also i feel like a ton of
comedians are in that
same boat is there ever times where you
maybe you're
recognized by someone and they expect
you to be like bouncing off the walls
because you're a comedian or you
introduce yourself to someone and they
find out you're comedian and like you
know they're like oh tell me a joke yeah
be extroverted i mean that's the thing i
remember i remember
[Music]
um in austin after after la in austin of
last year
2021 i had done
i think nine or ten shows in a row in
texas
and on the last
night i decided i would now say we're
gonna have an after party
and announced it at the show
and then a bunch of people who i just
spent my time entertaining
um
came to the after party and i didn't
realize that
i would have to
re-entertain them
yeah you know what i mean yeah
and it was in that moment that i
realized oh yeah like
i don't
i don't enjoy
like the
the
the expectation people have of
a comedian like in real life right it's
you know i'm like and i did i mean i was
i was shroomed out and i was having a
good time talking to everybody but
in that
hindsight i was just like man i just
want to be i was i was just on for you
know nine hours yeah basically like i
want to be off for a while
um
that isn't that's not to say like if if
i meet people in the street i'm not like
friendly and coordinate all that kind of
stuff but i always appreciate people who
are fans and stuff it's just
uh the idea of constantly being
entertaining i think it also like
disappoints people a little bit when i'm
just like hey man nice to meet you thank
you very much yeah yeah like hey i've
got a nice shirt you got dad
it's never that yeah oh thanks man i
appreciate what you're doing then i'm
gonna go eat my sandwich you know yeah
that there's it's weird probably meeting
people with expectations of you
and they're just a rant like a random
person that you don't know at all and
they're like
they already have in their head what
this interaction is supposed to be like
yeah it's got to be impossible yeah yeah
yeah no but i i'm always i'm always uh
grateful that i get to meet people and
people are fans of mine yeah no one's
been an [ __ ] yet so yeah so you just
said austin
was kind of like 2021 yeah
doing some shows down there and that's
kind of you know the beginning or
like austin's going through this like
comedy
transformation like trying to become
this big and is becoming this big
third home maybe even second home
between new york and los angeles for
comedians and comedy did you see any of
that when you were down there do you see
um like a scene developing there and no
i mean i wasn't i was there just for my
[ __ ] you know i was never i wasn't there
exploring the comedy scene anything like
that i went i think i did uh what i do i
did
uh
dallas
to austin
to houston
uh and then back to
uh
austin
i think that's i think that's how the
run went from what i remember so i never
even had much time to like hang out in
these places i just went did shows
bounced you know did bounce yeah that
was that was my run
um i could see austin becoming a
slightly bigger scene but again like i'm
i'm talking out of my ass when i say
that like i don't [ __ ] know yeah
so you're obviously part of the job of
being a professional
touring comedian is the constant travel
city to city like you just said bounce
around texas but also the whole country
recently there's just been like so like
it's so [ __ ] hard to have your
airline just be like
reliable
this is uh not that serious of a
question but like what happens
when you have a live event that people
bought tickets for what i don't know if
this ever happened to you but like with
uh traveling issues or like a flight
cancellation people are waiting on you
like like connecting flights you got one
day to get to another city are there any
issues with that for a community i've
been blessed
um by delta
you know
but no duffy i think coming from
from chicago to philly last year we got
[ __ ] uh i had a bunch of shows and
i had four shows in chicago and then
two shows lined up in philly on a
wednesday and i remember like
you know eight out ten hours before my
flight to philly like we got canceled um
and i was like like the place got
canceled like [ __ ] what are we gonna do
yeah um and luckily we scrambled found
another airline to
get to philly but that's happened a few
times where i was just like oh [ __ ] like
i don't know how am i gonna get there
like on my flight to
my most recent flight to um
kentucky when i was going to kentucky
this i think it was in march or april no
it might have been may or whatever it
was but
um
it got canceled like a few hours before
and then i was like how the [ __ ] am i
gonna get there and i had to go to
another city and then hire a car to
bring me from that city too holy [ __ ]
you know that happens from time to time
you just gotta i just trying to i just
remember one time someone told me
uh a very famous friend of mine lost his
passport um in a foreign country
and
it didn't bother him at all um and i was
just like oh yeah you just gotta keep
that
kind of the same energy it's like yeah
all right it'll be fine like yeah worst
case scenario this show has to be
rescheduled and yeah uh
um
that you just got to live with that you
know like it sucks don't get me wrong uh
you know i had a bunch of shows get
canceled in february of this year
um
but you know we rescheduled them and it
all worked out you know it's just it's
just part of the part of the game you're
playing yeah that makes sense does it
ever [ __ ] with the show when you have to
do a whole crazy like renting a car
going to another city and then you
finally get to the venue and you're like
oh my this is the last thing i want to
do right now is yeah i mean that i try
to plan for travel fatigue in my in my
travel schedule um so i tried to be the
first flight in
uh
in the
first flight out but like first flight
install like i can spend the most time i
can at the hotel and you know get that
travel [ __ ] squared away and then go
into my
pre-show lebron like routine of like i
got a i got to eat i got a nap i got a
gym and i got a shower and i got to
clear my head like that that has to
happen
um for me to feel like 100 ready for the
show so you hit the gym before every
show
yeah i try to oh
it's just like it you know science just
shows is good for your brain
overall the it just helps me
uh get into like a slightly higher
energy
uh state of mind you know yeah do you do
that like for just regular week nights
in in the city too yeah every every time
every day i have a show i'll try to i
mean i work out quite a bit as it is you
know like i try to work out five six
times a week anyway damn um
uh and that's you know for health
reasons and for brain reasons so and so
i can look good uh
but
uh it definitely it definitely
i don't like kill myself if i don't get
to do a workout in before show but i do
definitely
uh have some kind of
superstition with it when i was like if
i worked out for the show it's going to
be a lot better than if i didn't work
out before yeah for sure would you say
that you're a health conscious comedian
yeah for sure i mean i try not to eat
like ass it's so easy to do
yeah and i definitely have eaten very
poorly on the road before um but it ebbs
and flows depending on which city i'm in
it's
really hard to find
very healthy food in
buffalo new york at you know 9 p.m on a
friday yeah you know yeah and those
chicken fingers just call you yeah and
are arguably like
uh they're not the worst thing for you
but it's like when you're eating them at
11 o'clock at night and eating fries and
then going to sleep and all that kind of
[ __ ] just all that compounds yeah
do you because i feel like i usually see
the clips of you and that's why maybe i
think you're so relaxed because you
usually have like a at least a drink in
your hand yeah like during the show
except in that is that
like you don't have to
give it all away is that for mostly
optics are you catching a buzz up there
do you like are you comfortable drunk up
on stage i think i think uh i think the
rumors of my alcoholism are gravely
exaggerated i think uh i think it's a
cop like i definitely have some clips
where i'm
on the
uh shouldn't be side of buzz buzz
but for the most part and that that have
stopped for sure like i don't drink on
stage anymore and i haven't um
for the most part but all the entire
tour uh it's usually it's usually
pellegrino or water if i'm having
something it's probably you see me like
on the last show of the run and i'm like
chill relaxed things have gone well
like in houston when i did
houston in april it was the end of a 13
show run where i did like omaha i went
from des moines iowa to houston with
like two nights off um yeah two weeks
she's
um and that was like all right kind of a
celebratory let me have a spicy
margarita i'm in texas i'm in houston
right spicy margarita on stage um but
for the most part it's waters for my
throat and uh and for optics you know
it's like
a good way to like give the crowd an
opportunity to break and and they see me
having a break and like yeah it helps
kind of build built-in transition time
yeah i like when i feel like i've seen a
few clips of you like making fun of some
dude's drink like he'll have like a nick
club ultra or something you call him a
[ __ ] that's so funny i feel like i've
seen so many clips of that yeah i've
seen like uh i think the shirley temple
one is my most favorite it's my most uh
yeah that's right traveled one night but
that's there was like it was like i knew
from the jump that these kids were like
they had traveled from new brunswick new
jersey to come see me in new york which
is a huge trick
um to see me do like 15 20 minutes and
they had like
such young energy and all four of them
had chili temples going it was so funny
it was so beautiful
yeah it's perfect yeah but i had to make
fun of him yeah is it i hear like
editing clips and stuff like that you
hear a lot about the
the camaraderie of the new york comics
and a lot of that's like going out and
having a great time is that something
like
is that a ton of fun is that one of the
best benefits of the job is just like
your co-workers basically are just a
bunch of fun
yeah alcoholic you know the the the
tough part with it all is that when we
become very good at our jobs that
opportunity to be co-workers
gets um
small and smaller you know it's like
right
norman's on the road i'm on the no road
stabbies on the road like anyone you
know the
chase like the people who are like come
up with and who are friends of mine who
when we see each other it's always like
you know like day one kind of [ __ ]
um but we very now it's like
we're on the road you know like yeah
free like that's one of my good friends
like i'll see him ricky bellez i'll see
them like
once a month or something if that when
we cross paths otherwise
you know everyone's just slaving away
doing chasing this dream of uh being on
stage you know yeah yeah that that's
kind of sad it is a little sad but it's
also like this is what we got in the
game for you know that's true at some
point it'll be
i think we're in the the heydays of our
careers this is like we're really
building something to
be the the next gen of people who can
sell at a theater once or twice a month
and then otherwise just hang out and and
have fun and build the art they want to
build you know yeah is it kind of is it
kind of like
a little trippy thinking about like you
you're just trying to so hard to get
to a point where like you're just
comfortable and you're so established
you can do whatever everyone you know
sell out anywhere but then once you kind
of get to that point it seems like
everyone that finally gets there that's
the busiest that they're ever going to
be and it's not even like i get there to
relax it's like i get there to do way
more work yeah i mean i don't know i
mean i i'm i'm not there yet uh
where i want to be i think i think
probably a year or so away from
um
where i'd like to be ideally career-wise
which is you know
selling out theaters comfortably
um
but i think once i'm there i don't i
don't know what mentality i have i know
the mentality i have now is i got to
keep going and getting to that point but
once i get to that point i don't know
what my time i might be like i need to
do arenas once a month you know who
knows yeah that's what it is um i just
know that
the people who are working very hard
like at the next level or two level two
tears above whether it be schultz or or
mullany or hassan like
these [ __ ] work their asses off
and they go crazy and then
that affords them the opportunity to do
whatever else they want to do um
and you know it doesn't feel like work
for them
uh at some point at least i hope it
doesn't and i know it it feels like work
for me and it is a lot of work for me
but at the same time it's like
this is great you know i get to travel
and
tell jokes and see the world and all
that kind of stuff and uh uh have a
great time doing it you know yeah hell
yeah well i really appreciate your time
today this was a a quick one but
definitely worth the conversation thank
you for having me finding nemish on
everything yeah find any mesh at uh
instagram at twitter tik tok
uh
youtube is nimesh patel but yeah please
go watch my special it's called thank
you china yeah hilarious news special
out on youtube um i love it we'll link
it in the bio of this one and then put
it on the little recommended things
during this video but yeah thank you so
much for uh coming on the show of course
man thank you for having me i'll talk to
you soon man yep thanks brother looking
forward
[Music]
you